british politics that brilliant
darwinian system as boris johnson put it
punishes vulnerability good afternoon
everybody
and even the man once famously described
as a greased piglet couldn't wriggle out
of this one i want you to know how sad i
am
to be giving up
the best job in the world
that them's the brakes
going but not yet gone boris the prime
minister is to become boris the
caretaker prime minister it is clearly
now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister and i've agreed with sigrin
brady the chairman of our back bench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now and the
timetable will be announced next week
and i've today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
it was a speech short on contrition and
it gave the impression of johnson as the
victim
rather than the agent of his own demise
since tuesday when key cabinet ministers
sajid javid and rishi sunat quit the
pace at which johnson's support
evaporated was astonishing
the chris pincher affair and what
johnson knew about previous sexual
misconduct allegations against the mp
was a scandal too far by thursday
morning the number of resignations had
passed 50 and counting
there's an old westminster saying that a
week is a long time in politics
well currently that unit of measurement
seems quaintly inadequate try an hour
maybe five minutes and there are many
conservatives for whom speed has become
vitally important they don't want boris
johnson hanging around for months until
a replacement is found they want him
gone now
george freeman for example who resigned
as science minister
sadly he carries with him a huge
magnetic field force of instability and
it's disruptive and divisive
and it's been our strength as a
campaigner it's been a huge weakness
as a prime minister in the government
as the last few weeks and months have
shown it
so who will be the next prime minister
mps would like the fields reduced to two
within a couple of weeks some are
already throwing their hats in the ring
in every private soldier's backpack
there is a field marshall's bat on
having seen the performance of our
cabinet over the last 12 months
i think
i would be encouraged to stand yes
past leadership races have shown
candidates are often successful because
of who they aren't rather than who they
are and if the conservative party has
any sense it will learn the lessons of
boris johnson's tumultuous time in power
rory challens al jazeera london